make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so getting into the new origin of
venom this is kind of cool right because
I don't know if I should say this but I
had it on good authority that the web of
venom the the venom the Vietnam venom
story was only one half of the equation
and that like time needed to be given in
order for the other half of the equation
to come out and explain the whole thing
so I'm so I was like okay I guess I can
wait I really don't want to but I guess
I can but the other half is here this
equation comes in the form of Wolverine
Captain America weapon plus number one
and the reason why is this is designed
to basically illustrate that like venom
is part of the weapons Plus program and
he was in that's a huge change that's a
massive shift from like what we expect
in terms of like the history of his
character and and the way this comes
about with regards to this one and in
the actual web of venom one shot is this
basically picks up with like Captain
America sort of going through and musing
about his own experiences about how he
became the super soldier so on and so
forth and then he's met by the arrival
of Eva the vessel of phantom X and then
like a hologram of phantom X himself now
the reason why this matters is because
phantom X is technically Weapon 13 now
he first appeared back a new x-men issue
number 128 and he was actually part of
Grant Morrison's whole run with regards
to like reworking the entire Weapon X
mythos right like the history of
Wolverine weapons Plus was always a very
clandestine and almost completely
unknown organization in the realm of
Marvel Comics right like the only real
explanation we got in terms of Wolverine
and weapons Plus came by way of the
little tidbits that we got from Chris
Claremont run and then Barry
windsor-smith Smarr will presents Weapon
X and that was basically it that's all
we ever really got we got small little
bits after that but we never really got
a cohesive story in terms of how it all
came together how it all functioned and
all that kind of good stuff and that was
until grant and worse and took over the
x-men and what he established in his run
was that weapons Plus was his
overarching program designed for the
purpose of essentially killing mutants
and or at least capturing them and then
containing them and then that was
basically the answer until you got in a
Daniel weighs Wolverine Origins and then
you got like you know Romulus and all
that kind of crazy stuff but regardless
of the scenario the way this was gonna
play out was like this Captain America
was the testbed right the idea was to
create weapons Plus and then basically
create weapons super soldiers whatever
you wanted to call them that would serve
the purpose of containing and
controlling the mutant threat Abraham
Erskine was taken blood taken from
Germany to the United States by Nick
Fury and the Howling Commandos and then
in turn he was brought to the United
States government he created the Super
Soldier Serum or at least
acted it and then it was ejected into
Steve Rogers you know the problem was
that Abraham Erskine died right off the
bat but for the most part it didn't
really we didn't really obstruct the
intention of weapons Plus because the
idea was to send Steve Rogers into World
War two and see how combat effective he
would be and if he would prove to be
combat effective he would be brought
back but a sample of the serum would be
extracted it would be used to create new
super soldiers they would all be
reconditioned including Steve Rogers and
they would go forward under the mission
of basically containing and controlling
mutants the problem with this was that
Captain America was frozen in ice and he
was believed to have been dead and so
that force weapons Plus to scrap the
whole project and then they started
picking up with weapons two three four
all the way up to weapon eight and
weapon nine and ten and then beyond now
for the character of phantom X he was
weapon 13 and weapons Plus as it
traditionally existed at least to say
are the time up to and at the point that
Wolverine escaped was basically like the
classic version after that it basically
kind of dismantled and then sort of
became like a reworked version of itself
that operated out of like Canada's
department H I think it was and then it
was just sort of off the books
clandestine and as it normally was and
the result was that when when phantom X
was brought in nobody really knew who he
was like we did we don't know what his
real name is I mean it's kind of Jean
plebis is jean-philippe it's kind of
what it's assumed to be but that's not
an absolute absolute answer but unlike
Wolverine he was conditioned in like
what was essentially an artificial
reality right like a man-made artificial
environment so that his mom would never
really know the difference and then he
was trained to more or less become an
assassin ultimately he ended up escaping
but what this says here and what he's
revealing here to Captain America enter
to Wolverine is that over the course of
his time where he's been away from
weapons plus he's been tracking down and
pulling in all these different clues and
strings to find out what was really
going on and how far the mystery of
weapons Plus goes and that's when he
drops the revelation to Steve Rogers
you're part of it right I mean this
hologram basically reveals Steve Rogers
was weapon one and that's one of the
cool things right because again it's
hitting at what Grant Morrison
established it's one reason is why Grant
Morrison's run on new x-men was so
significant because it changed up a ton
of things not just with regards to the
x-men but with regards to the Marvel
landscape as a whole and so what this
does here is it actually sort of jumps
back to 1945 with this young kid and
this young kids basically just you know
idolizing Captain America listening to
all the different radio broadcast things
like that
and he's actually there being picked on
but he's there at the time when the
broadcast is given the like Captain
America appears to have died in an
explosion and it's basically the end of
his character now
again it kind of becomes a school thing
because you sort of get these jumps
through time let you jump to 1953 you
end up finding out this young kid is a
guy named younger or younger however you
want to pronounce it and he's obsessed
with becoming the new Captain America
it's the one thing he wants the most is
to be the new Steve Rogers but
ultimately he's constantly turned down
and constantly told you can't be this
guy you're not good enough until he
loses his mind he shows mental
instability and then he's told now
you're ready like now you can become the
new the new Steve Rogers and that's one
of the big differences here is that when
Steve Rogers became Captain America it
wasn't because he was crazy it was
because of the fact that he was like I
really want to do the right thing right
like I really want to become a good guy
and I want to serve the best purpose
that I possibly can and so it was really
more of like a moral compass but there
are small little things that go on here
I mean for example like when Wolverine
and Captain America enter this world
weapons Plus facility were these these
animals are basically being experimented
on which really encompasses a brunt of
the operations between weapons 2 through
9 we end up finding out that there's
equipment here from like Obadiah Stane
z' corporation Oscorp from Norman
Osborn's corporation there's a lot of
stuff here that was used by weapons Plus
from a lot of these organizations that
are traditionally associated with
villains you also end up having like the
headband of Luke Cage right so like Luke
Cage is now part of the weapons Plus
program it's one of the things that's
put on there right like the venom
program the power program right so Luke
Cage initially came out as Power Man
like it's these cool things were
basically ties in like the whole history
of the entirety of weapons Plus hitting
venom and basically saying he's a part
of this whole thing and so because of
that when they get in there and
basically like they're attacked by this
giant bear we end up finding out of
course that much like the other programs
in weapons plus the bear was genetically
modified and almost became sentient and
ultimately was destroyed we end up
finding out you know kind of jumping
again back to 1974 that when you had
Carroll Hines you had dr. Abraham
Cornelius and you simply had the
professor professor Truitt I think was
his name that this guy Junger was part
of the project that originally created
Wolverine right so like he's been there
throughout the entirety of the whole
thing and he was always trying to become
the new Captain America he was always
trying to become the newest project for
weapons plus and that is until Wolverine
and Steve Rogers show up where this
newest facility seems to be located at
when they get there we end up finding
out that
Junger basically modified himself he's
got this kind of sewn together Captain
America suit
he's got the healing factor of Wolverine
everything's sort of popping off here
now of course we you have like Captain
America and Wolverine fighting against
him the newest individuals who were
running weapons Plus at the
we're watching the whole thing unfold
and then basically below the lap right
because it's kind of like we need to
destroy this whole thing as opposed to
letting our evidence fall in the hands
of like the x-men or the Avengers right
because if the x-men of the Avengers got
their hands on all this evidence and
basically said weapons Plus is still
around weapons Plus still functions then
like the whole world is going to know
about it the whole world is going to be
aware the irony of all this is that if
the world was aware it wouldn't really
matter it wouldn't really matter at all
now the reason why I say it wouldn't
matter is because in the The Wolverine
Captain America one of the Captain
America comic we ended up finding out
that Nick Fury was part of the weapons
Plus project or at least helped to
oversee it while he wasn't really like a
director of it he did have a hand in it
and so when you jump to this web of
venom one shot you end up finding out
though like in the early days of course
when you ended up having this sort of
his dragon symbiote composite it was
essentially frozen and ice and stuck on
earth and eventually discovered by
shield and when it was with Nick Fury
overseeing the project they extracted a
samples of this material not knowing
what it was from this giant you know
symbiote dragon and then in turn bonded
it to like Rex Strickland these guys who
were part of the original platoon that
had been talked about during Donnie
Cates run on venom and so with that
being the case like they were sent out
for the purpose of using the symbiotes
to see how effective they would be now
this whole thing happened during the
Vietnam War that's why I say it wouldn't
have mattered because what you're
talking about here is you're talking
about Nick Fury and Nick Fury doesn't
really specify who it is he answers to I
mean it is kind of like the the world
Security Council or at least any
Ultimate Universe it is and this one it
was it what it was to a degree until the
events of near of Fury's secret war when
he ended up finding out to the Security
Council was replaced by life model
decoys and since then Nick Fury had been
running shield on his own up until that
point sometimes beholding to the
president sometimes not but what he
seems to indicate here is that those who
are running weapons Plus are those who
were he who he's answering to because
they're the ones who were basically
working with fury with regards to this
great big huge project and so because of
that you know this was essentially a
weapons plus experiment that's exactly
what this was take whatever this
material is if it can be weaponized and
be used to create super soldiers bonded
to human beings and then send them out
into the Vietnam War have them face off
against the Viet Cong soldiers and see
how these symbiotes work the problem
with this is that when that happened the
symbiotes seemed to go crazy right and
like immediately started attacking
everything but what would happen is the
members of the platoon rush Strickland
and these guys would pass out then they
would wake up next to a pile of dead
bodies because the symbiotes basically
consumed them right because these
symbiotes as they existed back then
were functioning based on the leftover
wills of null the symbiotes got the kind
of last command he gave them which was
essentially consume and destroy things
kind of expand the Empire as though it
was a cool little moment because these
guys just kind of been frozen right so
when you follow the the the chronology
of the symbian were null eventually
created like initially created them and
used them to expand his own Empire and
then Noah was eventually defeated and
the symbiotes retreated to a section of
space took over an entirety of a planet
like you saw in Brian Michael Bendis as
guardians of the galaxy and then
reformed themselves to become good guys
for these symbiotes that never happened
because they were never part of that
group they just kind of been frozen and
locked away all this time and so because
of that when all this sort of sort of
explodes Nick Fury basically goes to
Wolverine a says like we are going to go
touch this up we're gonna quiet this up
as best we can because what we don't
need is the world to figure out but this
is what we've been doing and so as they
stumble across the path of these oddly
remains that are left over they end up
coming across
Rex Strickland himself who basically
says hey look my symbiote bailed on me
things popped off I have no clue what's
going on here but like you guys have to
get me out only for the real Rex to show
up and say that guy's a symbiote
pretending to be me right so like the
ability to shape-shift the ability to
pretend to be other people all the way
down to the point where it seems to fool
Wolverine now this is one of the things
that Donnie Cates kind of toys with
because in Marvel Comics we'll reins
ability to detect whether a person is or
is not someone else is really kind of
predicated on his ability to having have
encountered them before right so if he
had met reg Strickland once before and
then showed up here then he'd be able to
sniff that out and say that's not Rex
but with Wolverine having never
encountered her send me it before and
having never met Rex mr. Bob before he
wouldn't know the difference but with
that being the case suddenly they're set
on all sides by all these different
symbiotes would you essentially taken
over the bodies of the of the the other
members of the platoon which again falls
in line with what we've seen in Donnie
Kate's venom run so far and then in turn
he and Wolverine seem to be the only
ones that are really left a lot and of
course this leads into into Nick Fury
basically shooting you know revealing
that he's there and and all three of
them kind of face off against these
simians as best they can rec Strickland
like flees for his life will rain tells
him to get out of here and it's one of
the crazy things because in that moment
the symbiotes end up taking wolverine
and bonding themselves to him and then
wolverine becomes venom for like a very
very short moment in time because of
that ends up you know resulting in rush
Strickland coming back taking the Venom
symbiote off Wolverine using fire and
then that's what is revealed this
version of Nick Fury is a life model
decoy
now at the outset you could look at this
and you could say okay so this is
basically just like Donnie Cates taking
the easy way out but no it's not and the
reason why is because it falls perfectly
in line with the events of original sin
those of you guys who read that story
back when it first came out a few years
ago
original sin basically show this
revelation that like Nick Fury and his
infinity formula had actually been
running out the Infinity formula had
been gone for some time and he had to
have consumed it on a regular basis when
he stopped doing that it stops slowing
his aging and so he just ended up aging
up and becoming very very old and so
what he did was is every single time we
ever saw Nick Fury he was running around
with life model decoys so it basically
fits in perfectly in line with what
Marvel has been doing over the last you
know however many years especially when
it comes to original sin and so when
that happens Nick Fury basically says
look I appreciate everything you guys
have done here but the world can't know
about this the world does not need to
know this is what we did because if they
do then suddenly every major
governmental agency is gonna want their
hands on this symbiote technology we
don't need that and so because of that
what he basically says is your service
has been respected I appreciate
everything you guys have done but now
you guys have to die and it starts
counting down this timer starts counting
down to zero starting from one minute
and in that time between Rex Rex
Strickland and Wolverine they take out
as many symbiotes as they possibly can
but in reality they're not really doing
a whole lot against them right because
these are more powerful than your
standard run-of-the-mill semia that we
saw with venom and so what is up
happening is that the symbiote that goes
to attack Rex Strickland ends up feeling
remorse for the things that it did and
so what Bond's itself to Rex and then
basically tries to shield him from this
explosion of the life model decoy but it
doesn't work and so as a result of that
basically Rex Strickland is totally
incinerated and the symbiote takes over
his physical form tying in yet again to
what we've seen in the venom ongoing
series and so as a result of this it
ends up being one of these things works
like do you want to do you want to go
out and like hunt aliens you know it's
basically Nick Fury talking to talking
about Strickland again all this taking
place in the 1970s or so and the
response of Rex is yes so basically
again you know it's it's it's it kind of
explains the backstory the origin of the
Venom's to be a program the fact of the
venoms to me it was part of it was
discovered by Nick Fury and the agents
of shield they was co-opted and brought
into weapons plus so it was part of the
same project that created like Deadpool
and Wolverine and Captain America and
all these guys it's a huge huge change
to the landscape of Marvel with regards
so like a lot of the characters that
exist out there to take all these
various characters and
roll them all up and tie them all in if
I'm if I'm being honest I think they're
doing this because this is how they're
gonna bring like Wolverine and the x-men
into the Marvel Cinematic Universe this
is gonna say all these guys were part of
weapons plus like after Captain America
was frozen and ice Hydra is part of
shield or what-have-you they created
mutants in the whole nine yards they
engineered them whatever the case says
but like this is where all this stuff
stem from which is kind of ironic
because that's the video pitch that I
had like six months ago with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to
comments explain a mission you guys are
the sub button to become part of the
rob4 if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]